morning everybody seven o'clock here in
the uk very welcome to spend your
breakfast with us here at
sky news fire and fury from nature as
wildfires burn around the world and
today on the programme
the u.n will reveal its long-awaited
climate report into the extent of the
crisis facing the planet
we're joined by the business and energy
secretary quasi quartens shortly to ask
is the government really on track to be
net zero by 2050
and how much will we all have to pay to
go greener
also our holidaymakers being ripped off
by firms over charging for carrying out
covid19 tests
the health secretary sergey javid wants
an investigation into exploitative
practices
we'll talk to the travel expert simon
calder about what's on the market
and in addition nature knows what it's
doing
and we really don't i mean this
is extraordinary and will calm you down
immediately
trio a wake-up call comedian ruby wax is
on the program to tell us
what the pandemic has taught her about
how to survive life it's monday
the 9th of august the starkest warning
yet as wildfires burn around the world a
major u.n climate change report will
spell out
how big the crisis facing the planet
truly is
i'm on the island of evia where
thousands have been forced to flee their
homes
as wildfires continue to burn here in
greece and other european nations
well hello from greenville here in
northern california among the
plumas national forest then it is right
now a town utterly destroyed
and after a rather unsettled weekend
there's some glimmers of hope this week
with drier and warmer conditions for
some i'll have the details for you later
and i'm here in minsk one year since
disputed elections set off a wave
of protests brutally crushed by the
regime we're about to head in for a big
conversation it's called with the man
known as europe's last dictator
i'm a marvel arch where this
multi-million pound mound has had to
scrap its entrance fees to try and
encourage
visitors
and fighting for his life now the prime
minister's
dad joined calls to save geronimo the
alpaca
from being destroyed
[Music]
it's going to be flipping busy isn't it
i know now the starkest warning yet
on climate change is about to be
revealed
uh in just two hours time the un will
lay out its report into the extent
of the crisis facing the planet and how
soon global temperatures
could rise to a level countries pledge
to try to avoid
we'll bring you the latest news
conference live on the programme
and that's at nine o'clock this morning
uk time it comes as wildfires continue
to rage around the world
turning the skies orange across parts of
greece in a moment we'll talk to our
correspondent
live just north of athens and we'll
speak to the business and
energy secretary quasi quatern first
this report from katarina vitozi
we've had months of extreme weather but
prepare
for stark warnings that what seems
incredible now
may become normal in the future the un's
ipcc report will assess our planet's
current climate
and use groundbreaking modeling to
predict what's ahead
we expect projections of hotter days
making things like wildfires more
frequent in places you might expect them
but also in those you wouldn't
this was west yorkshire in 2019.
this bit of the more was really badly
damaged by a fire into there's still
some damage that lurks
lurks below if we have these fire events
longer term they dry the moors out
and the drier they are the more likely
they are to catch fire again so we get
into this sort of cyclical nature
and if fires here become more frequent
it will lead to floods
we had some some heavy rain about an
hour ago and already all the streams
have come up really quickly
it can sort of hold back the same amount
of water that it used to do
the ipcc reports are the most
significant reports
in climate science the previous one
formed the backbone
of the historic paris climate agreement
in 2015 which saw world governments come
together
and pledge to limit global warming to
ideally
1.5 degrees celsius so
what can this new report do published
just months ahead of the un climate
conference in glasgow
[Music]
in june we traveled to bangladesh and
saw the impact of rising sea levels
and intensifying extreme weather like
cyclones
previous ipcc reports established the
link between global
warming and human activity expect more
on that in the report
and that may sound bleak but really it
brings
hope that the worst of a crisis created
by humankind
can be avoided if action is taken
catherine of a totsi sky news
pleased to say that quasi cartoon the
secretary of state for business
energy and industrial strategies with us
here on the program this morning good
morning minister you hello on the
program
um are we on track to uh hit net zero
emissions by 2050. i think it's
challenging
but i think we are on track i think
we're doing quite well if you look since
1990 we've reduced our emissions by 45
percent and we've managed to grow the
economy by 80 percent
this is a world uh beating figure people
around the world
particularly in this year of cop 26 look
to us
as leaders and i'm very pleased today to
be going up to the humber region to
announce
more investments from siemens gamiza in
building their wind turbines
and also gri renewables it's a package
of about 1
340 jobs so it's really really a good
sign well
so are you saying we will hit the 2050
target well it's 2021 now i think
there's every chance uh we will hit the
target it's a lot of work
um but i think we we can do that so it's
challenging though isn't it it is
challenging i mean
it's not it's not an easy thing if it
were an easy thing we wouldn't be going
on about it
leaving the world as you said um alex
sharma he's in charge of cop 26.
he says we are dangerously close to
running out of time to
avert catastrophic climate change and
we'll hear more from the un later on do
you agree with him
i think i think it's a critical uh
situation i think we've got to really
focus on delivering on net zero i'm very
optimistic that we can do it
but i think arloc is right to highlight
the risks of us not
being able to achieve that target and is
the best way to do that to jet around
the world
more than 30 countries i'm very clear in
terms of
his role uh cop 26 is a big
international event
it's probably the biggest international
event of international diplomacy that
we've hosted in decades
and he has to go and forge those
alliances he has to build
uh networks he has to deliver on
people's commitments and that does
involve
foreign travel isn't that what zoom's
for well i think zoom
has its limitations i think it's
effective in some quarters but if you're
trying to conduct international
diplomacy if you're trying to build
trust with other people i think
face-to-face meetings
are critical for that and you're
offsetting all of that carbon footprint
that he's
creating at the moment we're looking at
ways of uh reducing carbon all the time
across the government
uh buildings across uh public sector
buildings as well there's lots and lots
of schemes
things like electric cars electric cars
um are a pillar of your
green policy but the thing with electric
cars is there's no fuel duty
with them is there so and that brings in
something like 20 billion pounds a year
at the moment for the government so
that's a 20 billion pound hole that
you're going to have
once we've got electric cars instead of
fossil fuel cars
how are you going to what's that well
it's not it's not something that's going
to happen
overnight i mean it's not as if one day
everyone is
going to be having cars that have
internal combustion engines and then the
next day people will move
uh to electric vehicles it's a gradual
process we've said
quite quickly yes we do i mean but it's
still gradual until 2030.
it's still gradual till till 2030.
um and i think we're encouraging people
uh to take up evs if you look at evs now
they're electric vehicles sorry um if
you
if you take up an electric vehicle now
it's considerably cheaper than it was a
few years ago
we're trying to roll out uh charging
points and we're trying to affect that
transition
so it's not something that you're
worried about i think actually if i look
at all the range of policies that we've
introduced and the things we're looking
to achieve i think the electric vehicle
rollout is is something that that is
actually very encouraging
yeah but i'm talking about the black
hole that's being created because of
fossil fuels and no longer getting the
duty on that
not something that the treasury's going
to worry about because the treasury it
would appear who's worried about all
sorts of finances at the moment which
will well as you know i'm the business
secretary
and that's why i ask you you always ask
me questions about tax and levels of
how we're going to plug black holes and
that's obviously something for the
chance of the exchequer so
maybe you could address that uh to the
treasury there's nothing that you're
worried about i'm concerned about it but
i don't have the authority to
write budgets or dictate tax policy one
wonders if he might after the next uh
reshuffle
i'm sure he will he's doing a fantastic
job he's a very
collegiate uh excellent chancellor and
i think everyone in cabinet including
the prime minister is is
100 behind it so you would be surprised
if he was demoted in a reshuffle
look it's up to the prime minister all
those sort of personnel uh decisions
i think i think that uh rishi sanak is
doing a fantastic job as chancellor
i think he's an excellent colleague and
i look forward to working with him very
closely in the months and years ahead
i've not really answered my question
though well i've just said i'm not
it's not my job to say who's going to be
in which job or who who isn't that type
of question
you would be surprised if he was demoted
given that he's doing such a great i
think he's doing a great job
um you know lots of things happen in
politics things have
been surprising some personnel moves uh
can be surprising
after reshuffles and all the rest of it
i think he's doing a great job and i'm
very focused on working with him
to drive uh recovery after coronavirus i
digress because i wanted to ask you
about electric vehicles and the fact
that we we've got this row light where
you can plug your car in but it's
incredibly difficult to find one of
those we're not moving quick enough on
that are we what are you gonna i think
we need to i think we need to accelerate
uh that i think we're very focused on
trying to get the charging points
uh infrastructure up and up and running
and we're working with dft we're working
across government
dft department for driving thank you
we're working very closely uh with
colleagues to try and do that people
have
said that there are problems and that's
actually one on that i don't think so
i think we need i mean if you look at
the way in which electric vehicles have
been
uh taken up i mean we we started from a
pretty much a standing start five years
ago
there are thousands of these vehicles
now on the road and it's gonna i think
it's gonna ramp up
uh exponentially but we need to get make
sure that we get the the infrastructure
right the charging points so it's not
good enough at the moment but you've got
it in hand and
i think it's something that we can yeah
i mean if you look at where we've come
from on this
you know even just four or five years
ago there were hardly any electric
vehicles
uh over the last uh four or five years
there's been a huge uh increase
in people buying them and people using
them there's much more awareness of that
i don't drive uh an electric car now
but i don't drive a diesel car i haven't
driven a car in london for years
okay why why would you would you drive
an electric car
i would i would i mean the next car i
buy will be uh almost certainly an
electric vehicle and why are we
investing in electric vehicles
particularly rather than synthetic fuel
which apparently a lot of
governments feel that is is the way
forward rather than electric yeah i mean
it's a good question i mean there are
lots of alternatives
uh in terms of decarbonized power in
terms of you know decarbonized vehicles
electric vehicles have been invested in
lots of people are manufacturing them
i speak to car manufacturers all the
time and they're very much focused on
electric vehicles
and that's what people seem to be the
market people choosing
their own their own vehicles seem to be
directed and more focused on
electric vehicles that doesn't mean that
in the future we can't have
as you say synthetic fuels can we talk
about boilers as well where are we as
far as spoilers are concerned 40
i was surprised by this number i'm sure
my viewers will be as well 40
of uk emissions come from our homes
that's right a lot of that is to do with
boilers and and heating our property
in other ways as well what are we going
to do about that because you did
i was expecting a report wasn't i um at
the end of july which hasn't yet
arrived any low carbon heating strategy
yeah you're right so that we
and i was working on this you know for
more than two years when i was energy
minister as well
we were going to come up we are going to
come up with a heat and building
strategy which
identifies the problem and actually has
solutions to the problem
you've just mentioned which is that most
a lot of our
emissions are coming from um houses
which aren't energy efficient
and also as heat sources which are
have too much carbon in them basically
and the heat and building strategy which
is going to come out very soon
uh outlines it's been slightly delayed
why because we want to coordinate it
with
also the approach to cop26 and also the
net zero strategy which
uh my department wants to come out in
september so we want to make a big
a big push on that uh in september what
do people do about their gas boilers
what are you going to say about that
i think in terms of gas boilers um
there's no there's no
cause for alarm at all i think people
are going to have gas boilers but over
time just as with the
ics the internal combustion engine
vehicles uh we want to see a transition
but that that transition is dependent on
lots of other things happening i mean we
need to look at hydrogen
uh we need to look at heat pumps and
make sure that they're they're
affordable
so there's lots of things that have to
happen who's going to pay for them
um i think a mixture of people usually
it's
government will pay to to some extent
the private sector particularly and if
you look at offshore wind which
relates to the announcement i was making
today that was a private sector
80 percent of the investment there came
from the private sector so that
they they will pay a player part as well
so you'll help people buy heat pumps
we've always had a policy of helping
vulnerable
uh vulnerable people uh buy uh and
and and shift the transition from uh
make the transition from decarbonized or
carbon emitting sources of heat to
decarbonized uh
and we're gonna have to look at that
more more aren't we because people are
more and more working from
home do you think it's a good idea that
people work from home or does it hold
them back
i think flexibility is good i think that
if you're trying to make a career
it probably makes sense to actually meet
colleagues uh
and actually build a network under learn
from other people and i think that's
probably
best done uh in the in the workplace but
as far as i'm concerned
this is not something which the
government is going to dictate to
businesses
i think employers and employees will
come to their own arrangements depending
on what
what business and what what their
company does what do you say to your
staff
um i think that we should try and uh
come in uh maybe
two to three days a week at least but
it's a gradual process
no one's being forced uh back against
their will
we've got to make the environment very
safe but i think it is probably quite a
good thing to
to spend more time in the week at work
and that's just a personal view problem
is people who are coming to work are
being penalized financially aren't they
because
they're having to pay to come to work
people working from home are getting the
same money and they're not having to pay
to commute is that fair so where i think
as i've said i think it's up to the
employers
and the employees and the one thing i've
noticed is that different businesses
have a different tolerance if you like
of people being able to
work from home so if you run an
engineering business or an architecture
business you've got models you're making
models that you have to
combine without the colleagues it's very
hard to do that
from home but there are other types of
of work which
are easier to do uh from from home so i
i don't think
uh that uh we can make a hard and fast
rule on all of this
that wasn't my question though my
questions are people being penalized
financially
coming to work i don't i don't think uh
people are if you think about it because
most in most instances people will come
two or three days a week so there's
there's very few instances i think of
people exclusively working from home
or exclusively that's potentially
costing people 75 100 pounds a week
and if they're staying and working from
home they're not having to pay that but
as i said
in my earlier bit of the answer is that
i think that's up to the employers and
the employees to work out what the best
arrangement is
but you accept that there's a
discrepancy there that needs to be
locked up i don't accept
um uh anything all i'm saying is that
it's for the employers and the employees
and if
some and also they can change i mean the
same employer e
might work two days a week uh one week
and then
three or four days a week the next week
not quite sure what you're saying i mean
it's costing people to go to work isn't
it it just is
i'm saying that the process who are
staying at home are not having sure so
i'm saying across
a company i don't think it's the case
generally
that there will be people who are
exclusively working from home and others
in the same business who will be
exclusively working uh in in the office
that's that's what i'm saying to that
end you think that people should come
back to work for all sorts of reasons i
think there are good reasons
yeah i think there are good reasons to
come back to work but as i always stress
i think it's up to individual companies
individual uh
employees and employers uh to come to
their own arrangements
okay let me ask about geronimo um he's
an august story isn't he um
and the prime minister's dad has been
writing in the paper
today about it um he says tear up that
threatening letter minister
it's not a ringing endorsement is it i'm
not sure where stanley's coming from
on this uh my understanding is that the
alpaca was
tested positive um for tb and the rules
are that um they they have to be you
have to be cult because tb
is a really bovine tv is really really
damaging uh to farmers
and people who make their livelihoods in
agriculture and that's why we have the
policy
yeah i suppose my point is that this is
an absolute pr disaster for the
government you could have got ahead of
it last week and you didn't i don't
think it's a pr disaster
i think as you say it's an august story
um it's obviously difficult because
there's a lot of uh you know people
invested emotionally in
a story of an animal but there's a
policy and there's no reason why the
policy shouldn't be stuck to
just on a more serious note while i've
got you and i know we're slightly
running over time but i did want to ask
you about the gurkhas
they have gone on hunger strike three
gentlemen who have
served this country for a very long time
and their pension is 20 pounds
a month they feel that they're not being
treated fairly and they are prepared
to um have a hunger strike to the death
what would you say
i think that gurkhas are fantastic
soldiers who've had a unique
contribution
to british history in that military um
and i think
that it's very sad if they feel that
that that they've been treated
uh in this way i mean clearly you've
i've just heard of the story
uh now um and i'd like to look at
something we've had one of them on the
program
point is do you think it should be
looked at surely everything yeah 70 year
olds
starving themselves to death of course
it should be i mean for them to have
come to a point where this is the
decision that they've taken and they
want to take this pursue this path
of course that should be looked at but
so i'm not going to comment on
details that i'm not fully apprised of
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
thanks for taking the time we appreciate
it i know you've got a busy round of
uh speaking to the media this morning
i'm always pleased when you do us first
thanks
thank you uh just a reminder if you want
to uh catch up on
any of that interview or watch the
program when you're out and about
this morning then of course you can do
that you can do that
via our website you can do that via our
youtube channel you can do that via
twitter
if you would like to oh look it's
leaving us hanging there but that
happens sometimes doesn't it depends on
your wifi signal
now while fires are out of control
across europe we're hearing with
thousands of people evacuated from their
homes leaving the fires to destroy
everything in their path in greece the
country's second biggest island of evia
has been burning for almost a week the
prime minister says the situation is
nightmarish and british firefighters
have flown out to join an international
effort
to control the flames well our europe
correspondent michelle clifford is in
the town of limney on
evia now for us hello to you oh my
goodness me those poor people
who would have had that house behind you
good morning
uh morning care yes i mean devastating
scenes for them to
return to lynley was one of the first uh
villages on the island to be
uh evacuated and you can see what uh
damage the fires brought to this island
in fact uh the man whose family
owns this house behind me has just gone
inside to have a look he's clearly
uh very upset uh i was talking to him
and he said
what can we do they did manage to get
off the island some of the residents
have returned
today to see the state of their
properties they feel lucky
that a limited number of properties have
been burned here
but a lot of people are left without
power now left without water now because
they're on the edge of the
sea they were able to escape quickly uh
in boats and ferries but have a look out
there okay you can't see very far
because ash cloud and smoke covers the
entire
area and that's
well i think we may have just lost uh
michelle just
there she is i think she's coming back
to us now hello team michelle are you
back
yeah i'm back um i was just saying right
across the island
there is this um canopy of smoke
enveloping the entire area and it has
really been a battle because
there's been no rain for the last week
very high temperatures it means the
ground here
uh is parched and the greek fire service
is really
uh struggling uh to control the blazes
now they have got help
uh yesterday we met ukrainian and
romanian
firefighters who've flown in to offer
assistance there are also british crews
on the grounds now to help the greek
authorities but they really are
fighting i suppose something of a losing
battle because
rain isn't anticipated more high
temperatures
this week so really difficult uh
situation and you see this sort of scene
unfortunately
repeated in village after village right
across this island
okay fine thank you if i was also
blazing out of control
in several other european countries as
well two people have died on friday in a
forest fire in the
calabria region of southern italy it's
believed they were attempting to save
their olive trees
the island of sardinia also saw
wildfires engulf the outskirts of its
largest city
cesare over the weekend and an
increasingly desperate situation on
turkey was alleviated by the arrival of
rain
this weekend quelling fires that had
been carried by wind across the southern
coast
eight people confirmed to have died in
the country
over the last fortnight and this is the
scene
in spain in the valencia province on the
country's mediterranean coast
firefighters worked day and night
through the weekend to tackle fires
which rips through the dry
forest areas outside the city
a heads up for nine o'clock this morning
we'll have live coverage of the ipcc
report into climate change
so that is basically the un telling us
what they think is going to happen as
far as climate change is concerned first
time we've had one of those reports
since
2013 that will be covered also
extensively on the daily climate show
6 30 and 9 30 this evening
still to come on the programme for you
at halfway seven i'm going to be
speaking to the former chief scientific
advisor davey king
about what we can expect from the un's
climate report
then at 8 20 we'll be live at manchester
velodrome preparing to welcome home some
of our olympic
heroes as they arrive back later on
today they're on a ba flight
right now i believe that they will be
landing within the next
couple of hours um and they've got one
or two treats in store for them we'll
tell you all about that
and then at a quarter to nine we'll find
out why a father with
terminal cancer has challenged himself
to climb
england's highest peak
the taliban has claimed three more
provincial capitals in afghanistan
as their advances through the country
continue a pace
the city of kunduz the sixth largest in
the country
is the most significant game the taliban
have made so far in northern afghanistan
a taliban spokesperson told al jazeera
tv
that there is no agreement on a
ceasefire with the afghan government
and warned against further u.s
intervention in the country
at least 15 people have been killed
after a coach
veered off a road in western turkey
another 17 people were injured in the
crash
and taken to five different hospitals
for treatment the coach was traveling to
izmir
when it left the road
the belarus president alexander
lukashenko will face the press today the
man widely regarded by many as a brutal
dictator
is likely to face questions about
opposition protests
the forced landing of a ryanair jet and
the threat to a belarusian athlete
at the olympics who has now saw um
solace in poland i think joining us now
is our correspondent diana magnay who is
in belarus for us this morning hello to
you diana very good morning
so what what happens what's the plan
hi kay well it's one year to the day
since alexander lukashenko claimed a
landslide
victory in elections which were widely
conceived
as rigged which started off a wave of
protest which has been
brutally crushed by the regime i mean we
were driving around mints
yesterday there is not a hint of protest
anymore tens of thousands of people have
been detained
there have been numerous reports of
torture
in the country's detention centers
hundreds of thousands of people have
fled the country as you just said we saw
alexander lukashenko bring down a
ryanair jet to try and bring in a
dissident
journalist he is now flooding lithuania
and poland with iraqi migrants
as retaliation for eu sanctions and
any hint of protest has effectively been
crushed it is a purge
in this country last month raids on the
few remaining civil society
activists and ngos that are left and of
all the people
that i spoke to this time last year
around about the elections and in the
weeks of protests since
most of them have either fled the
country or are too scared to speak
so on the anniversary of that election
he has invited the western press
for the first time to what he's calling
a big conversation it seems to be a lot
of
belarusian state journalists russian
journalists and a few of us
western media who are waiting to go in
he tends to talk for a very very long
time at these events in 2019 he spoke
for seven and a half hours so we'll see
whether he actually answers any
questions or is held accountable in any
way
for this incredibly cruel crackdown that
we have seen over the past year why is
he doing this well
perhaps to signal that he has the
country back under control
and to invite us in to show that he has
okay
for now donald thank you of course dan
are updating us throughout the course
of the day here on sky news about that
news conference
she said he does talk for a very long
time a quick look at this morning's
papers uh still
lording the excellence of the british
olympic
team let's start with uh oh there it is
with
the metro first of all the greatest
cyclist jason kenny wins his
seventh gold medal on the final day of
the tokyo 2020 olympics i think
i'm right in saying that he is flying
home today
with his misses uh they're on a ba
flight should land about
10 o'clock apparently on board eight
goals
nine silvers and two bronze uh which
weighs in total
ten kilos of medals can you believe it
i'm also hearing that apparently if
you've won a gold you get a gold card
if you want a silver you get a silver
card and if you've won a bronze
you need to try harder next time so you
can get a gold card gleam gb
is what the sun is saying this morning
here a 65
medal miracle uh as does the express
honor heroes who lifted nation it says
picturing welsh
olympic champion lauren price who won
gold
in the range i think she's also on board
the aeroplane and the guardian
hails the miracle of tokyo on its front
page featuring team gb's olympic power
couple
laura and kenny uh laura and jason
kenny there they are celebrating i think
they've got am i right saying something
like 16 medals between them
most impressive uh absolutely ridiculous
as rich my director says it's amazing
liquid gold here's one way the team gb
heroes are being quite rightly looked
after as they travel back
to the uk look at that how cool
is that my goodness me i'm sure they've
not been drinking very much for the last
few weeks if not months and as a result
they'll be celebrating on board who
knows what they might be like when they
get off the plane
at heathrow that should make for some
interesting interviews
and in the next hour we'll be at
manchester velodrome as well
ready to welcome back some of the
olympic heroes when they arrive back in
the uk
later on today
now it's been called london's worst
tourist attraction now the 2 million
pound marble arch mound
has stopped charging people to visit in
an attempt to draw
more interest is what we're being told
uh joined by
jemima who has been sent to the mound
for us
this morning hello to you jemima i mean
it was an absolute
mess last week what's it looking like
now
yes it was a little bit of a mess wasn't
it kate it's looking
i would say marginally better now
there's a bit more flowers
and plants on the side so certainly a
little bit more decorative but we will
have to wait and see
whether the promise of a free ticket
will attract people
costs 2 million pounds as you were
saying open on the 26th of july it was
very swiftly closed because there was an
absolute
wave of criticism online people called
it london's worst tourist attraction
teletubby hill a rubbish heap so not
rave reviews
the intention was to attract taurus into
a part of london which has been really
badly hit by the pandemic
add some landscaping to an area which
has got a lot of congestion
the reality is there is still a lot of
congestion if you can see i'm kind of
right in the middle of a
very busy roundabout but we will have to
wait and see whether that promise of a
free ticket in august
will bring the visitors in so is it
actually open jamaica can people climb
it at the moment or not
so opens at 11 a.m so from 11am it is
open people start going up from then so
yeah it's open today
you can go online and look at the
availability so it is open for visitors
we'll start seeing at about 11 whether
people turn up i imagine the weekends
will be the slightly busier time
if the visitors do come it looks
ridiculous
okay it's jemima fernando thank you very
much and
it does so doesn't it i mean it costs 2
million quid
for that don't know go up the shard if
you want to get high up
a quick look at the weather for you now
here's hello to you nas i don't know
what you think of it good morning
i think it'll be useful for me to head
to the top of it and have a look at what
the weather's like
get a closer look right um not for 2
million pounds so
today's weather unsettled again
following on from the weekend
but i've got a little bit of good news
for this week
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning i'm going to start off with
some good news to start the week it's
looking somewhat drier and slightly
warmer for some
southern areas of the uk this week but
further north and west it's still going
to remain quite unsettled and today
follow suit from the weekend we continue
with showery conditions a
pretty wet start in fact across many
central and southern parts of england
and wales first thing some hefty
downpours
and elsewhere we are seeing some showers
further north and west
mostly showery bands of rain now going
into this afternoon and we'll see
the rain across parts of the south and
southeast clear off into the north sea
but then behind that there will be lots
of showers around in fact it's a
sunshine and showers kind of day for
most places
those showery bands of rain will become
more widespread breaking up into showers
that will be heavy uh at times with the
risk of thunderstorms and
hail particularly heavy downpours i
think for today across
parts of northern ireland particularly
to the east of northern ireland as well
as
for southern parts of scotland and
southern areas of england fewer showers
expected towards this evening
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now the business secretary kwazii
kuatang said it would be challenging for
the uk to meet its climate change
target but he believes that it is
possible
he was speaking as the un prepares to
deliver its starkest warning yet
on climate change and the extent of the
crisis facing the planet
speaking to me earlier mr kuateng said
the uk is on course to meet those
targets
i think it's challenging but i think we
are on track i think we're doing
quite well if you look since 1990 we've
reduced
our emissions by 45 and we've managed to
grow the economy by 80
this is a world beating figure people
around the world particularly in this
year of cop 26
look to us as leaders and i'm very
pleased today
to be going up to the humber region to
announce more investment
from siemens gameza in building their
wind turbines
and also gri renewables it's a package
of about 1
340 jobs so it's it's really really a
good sign
well so are you saying we will hit the
2050 target well it's 2021 now i think
there's every chance uh we will hit the
target it's a lot of work
but i think we can do that
at least four people have been reported
missing as officials in the u.s say the
dixie wildfire in northern california
is now the largest in the state's
history there's concern that winds are
picking up again
which could help drive the fire on mark
stone is in greenville
in northern california a town which was
in direct line of the fire
well hello from greenville here in
northern california among the
plumas national forest that it is right
now a town utterly destroyed you can see
behind me here
there is hardly a corner of this place
of a thousand or so people
that has been untouched by this latest
wildfire to rip through this part
of north america you can see here this
was the
the library the greenfield library the
sign itself damaged and as we move
around you can
make out the wall along which the
bookcases were once
and now simply a pile of ash this is one
of so many
communities right across this town so
many businesses
that have been destroyed we drove up
here from some of the larger communities
through the course of the morning and we
had heard the stories we'd seen some of
the images
of the destruction but you know it's
only really when you get here
that you can feel it and it's quite
breathtaking how much
destruction there is across the
community the positives and
you know everyone is looking for those
always the positives are one or two
houses
the owners of those houses so relieved
that they are
untouched those houses bizarrely
randomly have not been destroyed
the other clear positive is that most if
not all the people here
manage to be evacuated before the fire
uh hit but there are a few people
as of sunday night still unaccounted for
and they will continue to search
for them now this is another building
here you can you can make out it was
once a um a restaurant here the kitchen
on the other side as we move over you
can see the tables and chairs
still laid out now behind all this of
course is the conversation about climate
change
from a californian perspective there are
two issues the local one
is forest management the forests locals
say very badly managed for decades
a tinderbox being allowed to grow up
over decades and then there is the wider
issue
of climate change just how much the
climate is changing here
and the effect that that is having on
communities
right across the region well to that end
uh un climate scientists are preparing
to lay out a stark picture
of the current state of the climate
crisis in
a landmark report to be published at
nine o'clock this morning it's the first
time since 2013 that they've done it
of course we'll cover that for you
extensively here on sky news from nine
o'clock
this morning joining us right now is the
former chief scientific advisor
uh sir david king who has previously
served as the foreign secretary's
special representative for climate
change hello to you thank you
for joining us on the program this
morning sir david it's always a pleasure
to see you
what do you think we might hear later on
today
well good morning kay i think for the
first time we are going to get
a very bleak report from the ipcc
this by the way is the first of three
parts of their report it always comes
first part physical science basis second
part
impacts adaptation and vulnerability
vulnerability
and then the third part is the
mitigation of climate change
we have to wait for the third part to
see what their recommendations are for
action
which is unfortunate those will only
come out next year after cop
but what we are going to hear is just as
you've given
in your report from northern california
changes in the
earth's climate system are happening
throughout the world in
every region of the world and this
report is going to deal with this on a
regional
uh analysis basis
if we if we look at emissions reduction
and at the moment that is all that is
really on the table for cop26
emissions reduction will take at least
2050 to get us to net zero
and then there's another 20 to 30 years
before the the world's climate system
will stabilize
and even when we get to that point
sea levels will continue to rise not
only for the next hundred years
but for the next thousand years so what
what we can see
into the future let me just give you one
bleak aspect of this
which is go to southeast asia the whole
country of vietnam
is virtually close to sea level and will
be
subject to sea level rise
meaning that the whole of the country or
90
of the country's land will be under sea
water at least once a year
by mid-century in 30 years time now if
we take that
and that country is a very big rice
producer
as just one example of what's ahead of
us
you look at that film that you're
showing right now
the kind of devastation that happens
with fire
also happens with water and so what what
we can see
is really remarkably dangerous
changes happening in the global climate
system and i believe this report
is going to clarify that in fact
temperature rises today
are equivalent to where we were two to
three million
years ago we we have to go back that far
in time to match up to where we are
today
and i'm one of those who believes that
what we need
is to treat this really as a climate
emergency i would like to see
a security council for climate crisis to
be set up
to advise the governments around the
world not on a
four-yearly basis but on a monthly basis
what needs to be done we're looking at
pictures now
of the impact of sea level rise i think
the
the way forward has to be
yes deep and rapid emissions reduction
but we also need to bring down the
amount of greenhouse gases
already in the atmosphere because at
this level
arctic sea ice has been effectively lost
during the polar summer
talk to me about the uh paris accord if
you would is any of it
actually working
i think i think i would have to say it
doesn't look as if it is
and the reason is simply because
greenhouse gas emissions are continuing
to rise and the rate
of increase is continuing to rise
what has worked and this was delivered
very much by europe
is decreased costs for example of
renewable energy systems
[Music]
solar power wind turbines etc massive
decreased
costs which means that really for for
most of the world certainly between all
countries between the tropics
but for most of the world it is now
cheaper to build new electricity
production from renewable energy systems
now that is a very big advance but it
takes a long time for that to roll out
the second big challenge is the rapidly
emerging economies of the world
this big new middle class middle class
just over a billion in the year 2000
is now more like 3 billion this big new
middle class
demanding the same standard of living
that we have and i'm afraid the same
level
of consumption and of emissions
and this is continuing to rise so
if you look at india and china the
rate of growth of the economy at six to
eight percent a year
means that their electricity demand is
rising and then as the middle classes
demand more and more energy
so that rise is not just in proportion
to the population
increase but it rises in proportion to
the middle class
increase we welcome this new middle
class
but we haven't really taken into account
what the contribution is to climate
change globally
fascinating stuff let me just ask you
quickly before i let you go
um how worried are you about what
the earth will look like in 2050
well i'm very worried in the sense that
we can't possibly reduce emissions to
solve the problem
i believe this report is going to
explain to us that
uh as i've said sea levels will continue
to rise for the next hundreds of years
even the thousand years
because it's all in the pipeline what
has happened in the arctic
sea the exposure of the sea to polar
summer
has meant the loss of ice from greenland
at unprecedented rates
what we need well before 2050
reduce emissions as rapidly as possible
but also
remove greenhouse gases and repair
the climate systems the past tipping
points
i'm expecting that for the first time
this report
will refer to tipping points but it
doesn't really recognize
yet that the tipping point has already
been passed
in the arctic circle region we have to
do what we can to try to re-freeze the
arctic sea
during the polar summer that that in
itself would give us
would buy time to allow us to do
considerably more in terms of managing
our future
but it looks very bleak to me at the
moment
we need to see an appetite for world
action
going beyond just net zero by 2050.
that is really my key message okay good
to talk to you thank you
for joining us this morning appreciate
it uh nine o'clock is when we're going
to hear
uh more on climate change the biggest
climate change
report since 2013. um
have a look at our graphic that we've
been showing you all through the week
last week
um if you weren't with us let me just
explain it to you it looks a bit
complicated to start with
it's very straightforward as soon as i
explained it to you the top line
that is the real-time power mix
in other words which percentage we are
using of renewables which is
nuclear which is uh fossil fuels you'll
see nuclear has gone up
quite a lot actually since last week i
think it was in the teens last week
that's what it is today um global
warming that is the figure uh
you can see how much warmer the earth is
now than in 1880
when modern record keeping began so you
can see it's 1.23 degrees
warmer now than it was when records
began
scientists believe it will take the next
figure how long it will take to get to
1.5 degrees
celsius just 11 years and that is the
figure
seen by many as a point of no return for
the planet just 11 years away
and then finally a huge and frightening
statistic
uh the total amount of co2 emissions
in millions of tons being used
being emitted in real time
more on that from nine o'clock this
morning
now our holiday makers being ripped off
by firms over charging for carrying out
covid19 tests the health secretary said
javid has asked the competition watchdog
to investigate what he's called
excessive pricing and exploitative
practices
among pcr covid testing firms
he tweeted this people should be able to
go
on holiday whether it's to see family or
just to relax
without fearing excessive fees for pcr
tests that's why i've asked the
independent competition and markets
authority
to see how we can crack down on unfair
market
practices we can speak now to simon
calder the travel editor of the
independent newspaper hello to you simon
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning uh what do you think are we
being ripped off
oh certainly yes there's absolutely no
question of it i mean
let me give you an example this is what
you are going to have to pay
58 pounds for which is towards the
bottom end of the uh
expectations and typically it's around
70 pounds and effectively it's just a
few bits of kit
you take your own swab you then post
that away and then hopefully
you get your result within a couple of
days
and this is a legal requirement for
anybody
coming back into the uk you can take the
test at the airport when you arrive but
you've got to have a pcr test
within two days of your arrival and if
you're coming back from an amber country
and you haven't been vaccinated
that's going to be another test as well
add that to the pre-departure test which
can be a lateral flow test
coming into the uk basically you're
looking at about a hundred pounds per
person uh which clearly um is adding a
huge amount i mean i've been away a
couple of times to
europe since we were allowed to in may
and on both occasions
my testing has cost more than my
airfares so
there's huge amounts of profits being
made um
it's interesting that they've chosen
this time second week in august to
get onto the competition and mark its
authority and actually the problem
doesn't seem to be
lack of competition they got 420
suppliers
but clearly lots of money being made
because nobody actually wants one of
these tests
we simply want to um get on with our
lives after having come back to uh
beautiful britain from our holidays and
um unfortunately uh
we have to take them so i calculate 300
million
pounds has been spent by british
travelers um
since april coming back into the uk and
august is going to be peak
testing the government has stipulated
this and i tell you what k
the travel industry is furious partly
because they think um it's way too late
to be
weighing into this and uh actually it's
the health secretary is kind of
responsible for
us needing to do this and secondly it
signifies
that because have asked for an inquiry
this isn't going to go away
anytime soon and so therefore people
will be obliged to test well well into
the autumn winter
perhaps next year perhaps every year
it's going to be part of our
um regime and uh clearly huge
cost implications and if you have to
test positive
on day two well it's not only you it's
everybody on your plane if you're flying
on one of the low-cost airlines
who's going to be at least for the next
week and ask to self-isolate
what's also frustrating i suppose for
some is that the government is actually
giving lateral flow tests for free you
can just uh contact a website and they
issue you with a half a dozen or
whatever seven i think there isn't a
pack
but you have to pay for a pcr test which
basically is doing more or less the same
thing
is there not an argument within the
industry for saying you should be paying
for this as well
well yes i mean the government has
always taken the view if i'm going on
holiday
i pay for any testing and i think a lot
of people would say yeah it's not right
to have the nhs effectively subsidizing
my holidays
um lateral flow tests um which of course
are
absolutely ubiquitous i've taken dozens
of them i'm sure you and your colleagues
have as well
um but the thing is the government says
we've got to have a pcr test when you
come back because if it's positive
we're going to sequence it and we're
going to find out what variants are
coming into the uk
which is not a bad idea except that the
viral load from people who are testing
positive is often
so low that they can't actually test it
and it said that fewer than five percent
of these things
are actually uh positive results are
actually sequenced so
there's an awful lot of people paying an
awful lot of money
without very very much reward okay
why are you there sam are you going away
no look this is a place of celebration
okay
um as from 4am yesterday people can
arrive from france this is the euro
style terminal correctly i can
i i would love to be stepping on board a
train to paris and connecting to the
south of france but i'm not
however eurostar saying they're selling
four times as many tickets
this week as they were last week okay
fascinating simon thanks very much
indeed appreciate it thank you
uh knowing how much time a woman has if
she wants to have a baby has until now
been difficult to predict but new
research
into the menopause from scientists at
the university of exeter cambridge
and copenhagen might change all of that
their findings
could lead doctors to be able to tell
women how long they have left if they
want to start
a family let's talk about it should we
joining us now
is anna murray and she is a professor of
course from the university of
exeter hello t thanks for joining us on
the programme this morning
what's your research found about the
menopause
well we've been investigating uh
reproductive
aging and one of the key time points in
reproductive aging in women is the
timing of menopause
and we've known for many years really
that there's a genetic component
to the variation in menopause timing
and our study has looked at the genetics
of more than 200 000 women from
many studies across the world and we
found
that there are about 300 genetic
variations
that influence the timing of menopause
in the in the sort of average range and
those each each individual variant
just affects menopause by from as little
as a few weeks
up to actually a few years so this is
really a big advance in our knowledge of
the genetic component of this trait that
obviously affects half of the
the population and what we can do with
this is start to understand
particularly some of the biological
processes that are really key
and what we saw was that
um a process that repairs
damaged dna seems to be one of the
really key things
that's involved in determining the
timing of a woman's menopause
and the reason that it's important one
of the reasons it's important to
understand this timing is because of the
link between
menopause timing and fertility we know
that women become
naturally infertile several years before
menopause
so an understanding of this reproductive
aging process we hope will help women
um with their fertility okay why
i wonder why it is that life expectancy
has risen
over the last 150 years but the age that
most women hit the menopause has
remained about 50.
yeah well that's really interesting i
think so the genetics can actually kind
of help us understand that and i think
the
as i said a lot of the genetic studies
of aging
are showing us that the the processes
involved in
determining age are much more about
diseases of old age
whereas the genetics of reproductive
aging
is quite different and many of the genes
seem to be acting
very very early in a woman's life in
fact right back to the time when they
were a fetus
and that's because menopause is largely
determined by your ovarian reserve
so the number of eggs you have in your
ovary and that gets laid down when
you're actually a fetus before you're
born
and then you lose eggs throughout your
lifespan and it's when you get down to a
very low number of eggs perhaps around a
thousand that you go through menopause
so that's why i think the two processes
are probably
quite distinct that's fascinating stuff
professor
really interesting thank you so much for
taking the time to join us we appreciate
it thank you
it's a pleasure thank you